- Well, Jacob, did you get Tom and Zendaya
Christmas gifts yet?
Did you get them gifts yet?
- Yeah, Jacob?
- Yeah.
- Well.
- Yeah, Jacob?
- The funny thing is, you know,
we were supposed to be on the show,
but so sorry we couldn't make it,
but I wanted to gift them
something from your show, Kelly.
I wanted to actually give them the mugs
that come on your coffee
table if that was possible.
- So, Jacob, you are a re-gifter
is what we're saying here?
That's what we're saying here.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I was gonna give you mugs
and you're just gonna repackage them up
and re-gift them.
- It would have been an amazing moment
in our friendship because I think that,
you know, being on "The Kelly
Clarkson Show" is amazing.
(Kelly laughs)
- So, you know,
I think that would've been a nice-
- Nice cleanup.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Yeah, well done.
- Jacob just stole my gift
to give you, it's fine.
(audience laughs)
I will send you all mugs,
I will send you all mugs.
Did y'all get Jacob anything?
Just wondering, I'm
calling all of you out.
- Huh, huh!
- We got him a lifetime of friendship-
(audience laughs)
And love.
- [Zendaya] And that should be enough.
- I knew it exactly, thank you.
- The number one movie in the year.
(Jacob laughs)
- We wanted to get each other,
like, a commemorative gift
for being in these movies.
We've done these movies
together, we've grown up together
since we were like 18 years old,
so we wanted to get like
a Spider-Man themed.
- Great.
- Not exactly holiday gift
but just like a special
thing that we all have.
Like a friendship bracelet.
- Like a tattoo, get a tattoo (laughs)
that you will regret in years.
You got a web?
Y'all should all get a web.
- Basically go anywhere to buy it, right?
You know, today is our
last day of work together.
It's actually really sad.
- Oh my god.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- So maybe after this today
we can go buy each other a present.
- Yeah.
Maybe that's what we'll
do after you have a nap.
- Yeah.
- And now it's a forced
friend gift brought
to you by me, you're welcome.